Nice to meet you, where you've been? I could show you incredible things.
Magic, madness, heaven, sin.
Saw you there and I thought, "Oh my God, look at that face."
"You look like my next mistake."
Love's a game, wanna play?
New money, suit and tie, I can read you like a magazine.
Ain't it funny, rumors fly and I know you heard about me.
So hey, let's be friends. I'm dying to see how this one ends.
Grab your passport and my hand.
I can make the bad guys good for a weekend.
So, it's gonna be forever or it's gonna go down in flames.
You can tell me when it's over, if the high was worth the pain.
Got a long list of ex-lovers, they'll tell you I'm insane.
'Cause you know I love the players and you love the game.
'Cause we're young and we're reckless, we'll take this way too far.
It'll leave you breathless or with a nasty scar.
Got a long list of ex-lovers, they'll tell you I'm insane.
But I've got a blank space, baby.
And I'll write your name.